pour ces lycéens le jock
la star miss populaire l'outsider
et l'étang bienvenue en détention garçons
et filles quel cosplay Hawker c'était un
club du samedi ils ne voulaient pas rejoindre
l'école est en cours de fumigation donc le
district a gentiment  arrangé pour que nous
restions ici et ce qui était autrefois connu sous le nom de
wave u prison Lexi puis-je avoir votre téléphone
[Musique]
mis dans ces couloirs pas ouvrir la porte
une fois que vous êtes à l'intérieur que voulez-vous pour le
mien Je vais trouver un moyen  dehors
il n'y a pas d'échappatoire bonjour est-ce que quelqu'un est
là à la place et s'ils vont
survivre à la détention cet endroit est totalement
hanté cet endroit était une prison
comme accord ly fou
merci de m'avoir envie encore plus de
spectacle de monstres je n'ai pas à  mettre de côté
leurs différences et trouver un moyen de travailler
ensemble c'est juste essayer de nous faire peur nous
ne pouvons pas le laisser prendre le
dessus sur nous ne s'en sortent pas vivants
juste des divertissements présente Gillian
vigman Alex franca Sara Davenport
Henry saga coy Stuart et  Jennifer Robi  n
Jacobs quelques activités
parascolaires ne t'inquiète pas bébé maman s'en occupe
ça pourrait être top sur le corps étudiant
détention mortelle
[Musique]